[Music]
I'm Brian Adams photographer and
Indigenous Alaskan and I recently
traveled to Juno Alaska to experience it
through the lens of Alaskan native
businesses and artists my first stop was
Alan Marine Tours a family and Alaska
native owned company offering day
cruises yep those are whales we
saw next I met up with artist Crystal
warl to learn about her public art we
visited some of our murals in downtown
Juno 1 two and three Crystal draws
inspiration from mlink at the alkan
Heritage in the natural
world finally I took a ride on the gold
belt tram which is Alaskan native owned
and operated they runs from the Juno Cru
port to the top of Mount Roberts where
you can catch some amazing
views there's still so much I want to
see in Juno and I can't wait to go back